[Music]
the election of joe biden as us
president
is the chance for the eu and the new us
administration to rebuild a stronger
transatlantic partnership
in light of the global pandemic and its
economic and social consequences
climate change and threats to our
democracies posed by populism and
disinformation
the need for international cooperation
has never been greater
joe biden is a traditional atlanticist
he is of the generation that remembers
the foundation of western institutions
so i think it's fortunate that we have a
group of seasoned politicians at the
helm of american politics who
remember and understand america's need
for
strong alliances visiting the european
parliament back in 2010
then vice president biden underscored
the value of parliamentary democracy
and the potential of a strong eu-us
relationship
together with my former colleagues in
the united states congress
you and i represent more than 800
million
people stop and think about that for a
moment
two elected bodies that shape the laws
for almost one eighth
of the planet's population that's truly
remarkable
the eu wants renewed cooperation with
washington to tackle global issues
the first priority is ending the
pandemic by ensuring the fair
distribution of vaccines treatments and
tests
and that the poorest in the world are
not left behind
while tackling kovid 19 is an immediate
challenge so too a climate change
the digitalization of our economies or
the fight against terrorism
the eu is proposing to build new
momentum on climate cooperation with a
joint commitment to net zero emissions
by 2050
from promoting shared values like
democracy of human rights
to opening dialogue on fairer trade
through reform of the world trade
organization
the european parliament believes that
now is the time for stronger global
leadership from the eu
and the united states
you